The evolution of antibiotic resistance
is such a serious problem that
evolutionary biologists
have started thinking about
methods of treating patients
that will not elicit an
evolutionary response.
Okay.
We,
we've seen the resistance evolves rapidly.
We're losing the CO evolutionary arms
race and there are some alternatives to
drugs.
One is slowing the emergence of resistance
just by using moderate doses and
targeting old age classes of pathogens.
This is plausible.
We think it can work,
but it's controversial.
Patients naturally want to
get a strong dose if they can.
Yeah.
Secondly,
we might be able to use viruses
themselves to fight bacterial infections.
Phage multiply in proportion to their
bacterial hosts with which they also co
evolve.
So this has been tested and it works.
Another possibility is to manipulate
bacterial public goods so that cheaters
invade and cooperators
cannot take over again.
And to a certain degree,
in fact,
successful infection
depends upon cooperation.
It depends upon social
behavior by bacteria.
So if we can disrupt
bacterial social behavior,
we may be able to produce an type
of treatment that doesn't elicit an
evolutionary response.
So the first idea is don't
wipe out the competition.
Use No more selection than is
necessary to cure the patient.
Okay.
This preserves clones of less virulent
pathogens that then compete with and
suppress the more Varian went ones and it
slows down the evolution of resistance.
Yeah.
Andrew Reed gave a great Ted Med talk
on this. You can find it easily online.
The second possibility is phage therapy.
So here is a picture of a phage is a
virus that attacks bacteria but does not
attack you. Carry Out. Excels.
Yeah.
Face have several advantages.
First,
they multiply exponentially
as do bacteria.
So a small initial dose of Phage will
multiply as they infect the bacteria and
that diminishes the need for repeated
administrations. In other words,
the dose self adjusts to the
intensity of the infection.
Phage also mutate during
replication as do bacteria.
So that produces new phase.
They can recognize altered bacteria.
In other words, bacteria
can't run away, uh,
genetically from the Phage.
The phage keep up with them.
Unlike traditional antibiotics which
kill useful bacteria that help us digest
food and produce vitamins.
Phage can be used to
target specific bacteria,
which reduces the chance that
useful bacteria are killed.
One of the problems with antibiotic
treatment is that it wipes out most of the
Microbiota and that allows resistant
strains of things like c difficile to
invade that problem can be
avoided with phage therapy.
Okay,
here is a timeline.
It's a long timeline and so it's small
and a little bit difficult to read.
I'll step through some of the high points.
The point is that phage therapy has a
long history and has had some success.
So phase were discovered about 1915
already in the 1920s they were being used
for therapy,
so there were experimental treatments
in the 1930s there were studies
of commercial feeds production.
However,
in the 1930s also the council
on pharmacy and chemistry,
which had a self interest in using
chemicals rather than phage concluded that
phage therapy is of questionable value.
In Eastern Europe.
There was an institute that was founded
to study experimental phage infections,
but in the 1940s the antibiotic
revolution came along and antibiotics then
overshadowed phage therapy.
In the 1980s experiments were done that
show that phage can be more effective
than antibiotics in some cases.
Okay.
In the 1980s the institute of Immunology
and experimental therapy in roll call
and Poland began treating humans with
phage therapy and over the next 20 years,
more than 1800 patients
were treated successfully.
More recently there has been phage
therapy for Vancomycin resistant bacteria
infections that were,
these experiments were done in mice and
also for methicillin resistant staph
Aureus.
So this is a promising technique and
it's one that bacteria cannot evolve
defenses against.
Okay.
So while the US and other countries
we're investing in antibiotics,
the Russians actually used
phage to treat bacteria.
Most studies show phage can be just as
effective as antibiotics and clinical
studies are starting in the United States.
Yeah.
Phage were recently approved for
protecting humans from beef that has been
contaminated with a
virulent strain of eco line.
Yeah.
And here are just a few
full photos to evoke.
Some of the cases in which phage therapy
has benefit effective for field wounds
for cholera and to sterilize
beef infected by equal one
phage therapy has both pros and cons.
Phage kill bacteria, they can't recover.
They automatically adjust their dosing.
They have low inherent toxicity.
The minimally disrupt
our commensal Microbiota.
There is no biproduct
resistance evolution.
They can be rapidly discovered
with screening approaches.
They can be applied flexibly,
they can clear out biofilms
that resist antibiotics.
There is potential for
just using a single dose.
There's a potential to transmit
protection to other patients.
There's little environmental impact
and they have low cost. However,
there are some problems.
Non Lytic phage are inappropriate.
It shouldn't be used.
They're narrow.
Host ranges can sometimes
be disadvantageous.
If you don't know which bacterium you have
precisely than the phage may not work.
They can evolve and they can
interact with our immune system.
However,
live attenuated vaccines do the same.
Now
the use of Phage for therapy against
bacterial infections also reminds us that
phage can be used to attack cancer
and there are some oncolytic viruses.
The idea is that you can have an inoculum,
which is these little purple dots.
Here are the virus going in.
The virus is a cancer cell living among
a bunch of normal cells and the idea is
to target the phage only to hit the
cancer cells and to leave the normal cells
on effected.
There are nonpathogenic viruses that
are being developed for this kind of
therapy.
They have none of the side effects of
chemotherapy and mouse studies of this are
very promising.
VSV is one candidate for the
use in human anticancer therapy.
Okay?
Okay.
Back to bacteria.
The third strategy for controlling
bacterial infections without producing an
evolutionary response is to
manipulate bacterial public goods.
So a public good is something that's
produced at a caused by an individual.
The benefits of the population as a whole
bacteria produce at least two kinds of
public goods,
molecules that signal the density
of the local population and side.
Dara fours that scavenge iron from the
medium bacteria need iron for their
metabolism. Now, both of these
are very Ellen's factors.
Bacteria will not attack host tissue
unless they sense that they are abundant
enough to overcome the host immune
system and they need the iron to grow and
reproduce.
So what you can see here is a diagram in
which bacteria are producing molecules
where the molecule by one cell
is also being used by another.
So
yeah,
if we can quench these virulence
factors outside the cells that has some
advantages,
extracellular action avoids resistance
based on transport through the bacterial
cell wall. So we don't have to worry
about coevolution of the cell wall.
Any fitness benefit to an emerging Mutan
will be diluted across all local cells.
As with any other public good
because of quenching agent may not
have previously been experienced.
That resistance has not evolved to
that particular quenching agent.
And this idea has been tested with gallium
treatments of pseudomonas infections
and it works.
Gallium is quenching the iron uptake
inside era fours and by flooding the
infection,
uh,
with gallium pseudomonas loses the
benefit of producing side era fours.
They aren't doing any good anymore.
So there's invasion by the variance that
aren't producing side era fours because
they don't have any advantage,
but they're costly.
The variants that don't produce
them invade. Once that is done,
the public good is knocked out.
Okay.
Okay. To summarize, because pathogens
rapidly evolve, resistance to drugs,
therapies are being explored to do
not elicit an evolutionary response.
Evolution can be slowed by
not treating too intensely.
This runs counter to conventional wisdom.
Yeah.
Phage therapy is promising and I
think certainly deserves a lot more
exploration.
Okay.
Disruption of bacterial public goods has
worked in a model system and might be
something that could be
carried out in a real patient.
I think that also deserves
more ex exploration.